Goodin good day everyone this is Jack
Van Horn from the big data it's in
training coordinating center located at
the University of Southern California
and I'd like to welcome you to the next
in our series of big data to knowledge
guide to the fundamentals of data
science we're absolutely delighted to
have Susana Assunta Sansone from the
University of Oxford speaking to us
today on metadata standards Susana is
the associate director at the Oxford II
Research Center which is a department at
the University of Oxford excuse me and
her research focuses on data
representation curation management to
support data reproducibility in the
evolution of scholarly publishing which
drives science as well as discoveries
she's the principal investigator leading
a number of programs in the UK and the
European Commission as well as being a
participant in the NIH as bd2k
activities
she's also the vice chair of the Dryad
board and a board member of the elixir
UK node which is the sort of a European
analog of the big data to knowledge
program the research data Alliance and
the force 11 taskforce
she has founding honorary academic
editor of Springer nature's scientific
data open access journal and today she's
going to be talking about metadata
standards and the interoperability of
standards to be able to promote
operational processes underlying
exchange and sharing of information
between different systems and how these
relates to the fair principles that is
the data should be findable accessible
interoperable and reusable and without
further ado I'll turn it over to
Susannah thank you so much for joining
us Susannah thank you so much for having
me and good morning or good afternoon
depends where you are but rain so um
here is the outline of my lecture today
so I tend to actually first introduce
the landscape of standards and started
with interoperability standard I'll then
narrow down the area and focus on
metadata and content standard and Alice
we knew what those are but them useful
for
and also illustrating the lifecycle of
those efforts and few key players I'll
close to discuss actually it's important
to help producer of the standard and
consumer of the standard to both make
discoverable those resources and for the
consumer to actually find the right
resource appropriate to its or her case
ok so let's start with a definition what
is a standard and of course this is a
definition because there are many but
let's say that it's actually an agreed
upon convention of doing something and
they can be established by by an
authority or by by grassroot group what
I really want to define actually are the
interoperability standard which is one
type of standard very driven to to what
we do and what the scope of this talk is
and the best example to use actually
it's one of the nuts and bolts and
therefore let's use engineering
engineering in the 19th century wasn't
as easy as it is actually now now you're
going by dry nuts they fit the redbones
and and that's it you know that they
will work together that certainly wasn't
the case before standards actually were
defined and that was actually in the
mean in the mid in 17th century but
those standards although were initiated
quite early well only adopted after the
Second World War so a century after and
that's a quite an interesting thing to
bear in mind because from the
development to the adoption of standard
there is a very big time gap now let's
talk of course about interoperability
standards in our area in the life
science and biomedical sciences so what
we are interested in our
interoperability standard for digital
object research output being
Deltan or codes algorithm workflow
model software or even paper of course
so actually in other cases those are
also agreed-upon specification
guidelines or criteria and they are
designed to ensure that is the research
object Digital research objects are fair
and fair actually means findable or
accessible are interoperable and other
useful so interpreting standard are
enables enablers and they Mabel out to
do better science in a more efficient
way to actually have straightforward
access and reuse of these digital
objects if you're not familiar with the
warfare stands for and what fair is and
the work behind it or what the
principles say in in detail I will
actually refer you to this ready
material so this is a publication in
that set if you did that at a group of
grassroots organization but also as you
can see
thunders the bd2k or infrastructure
developer and service provider in elixir
or other grassroots organization and and
advocator
with Indian Air Force 11 etc I've
actually promoted and they've endorsed
so the first principle I really am very
precise and measurable sets of
guidelines that allow digital object and
service provider they have interests at
reproduce evgeny object to make sure
that those are actually fair fundable
accessible and reusable it really the
third principle stress the fact that the
digital object should be just human
readable but should also be accessible
to machine and the article contains few
examples of implementations that are
working towards making date Holdings
fair actually because per have certain
they're different metrics metrics which
are being devised as well by working
group within the use okay
and those are just few examples and as
you can see there are groups within the
bd2k which are also working towards
making data fair or even standard fare I
will touch upon those as we go along
Linda in the talk so let's go back to
define the fundamentals of
interoperability standard so near the
Center for discovering data or code or
software and etc but also essential to
allow the site those digital object and
therefore credit and recognition to the
person that has actually shared and make
this object fair so we can say that
actually the nuts and the bolts of the
interoperability standards are metadata
and identifiers so these are the
essential elements to build an
interoperable machine and metadata and
identifiers are essential to the
underlying process the operational
process of interoperability which will
allows data or any other digital object
to be aggregated to be integrated with
another to be compared to the exchange
so although identifiers it's not the
focus of this presentation because
actually it requires a presentation on
its own I want to give you some pointers
and some reading material because there
is a lot of efforts around defining
unique resolvable and vegetable
identifiers which are essential for
digital objects so there are several
effort within the first eleven group
being the resource and the deputation
initiative and I believe an internal
scheme I actually present this in the
next lecture next week there is
identifiers for researcher defined by
your children five-foot-four data set
life for data science and so on and so
forth and there is also quite nice
summary document which will provide you
simple rules for designing and providing
and reuse persisting identifiers and
that's the reference that you can see
actually there is a preprint
in general dough and the paper is
actually been submitted so let's focus
now especially on on the metadata
element this interoperability standard
so but what the broad identifiers and
make a baby can need to be actually
implemented by by technical experts
so to have a machine that works well you
need to put together the nuts and the
bolts and that's where you need the
technical expertise you need the
modelers you needn't ologists you need
the software developers and so on and so
forth and we need tools when it registry
when it catalogues of these digital
objects we need databases for data when
it's service around all of this because
we need to ensure that the researcher
can actually find kinetics tour can
actually manage all this information and
they can do all they need to do in their
own research activity but we need to
allow them to make to make all this
quite seemingly less and we to do that
we need to make sure that this inter
ability standard is nuts-and-bolts are
invisible to them because usually
researcher have very little actually
knowledge and unfortunately very little
interest in wanting to know what is make
a data is and what they should use and
so on and so forth so making
interoperable standard invisible it's
the key to actually their adoption in
the success with the ends so talking
about metadata in particular now a bit
early that's actually it's it's a
descriptor it is krypter for for digital
from the digital objects they will help
someone actually to understand what the
digital object is or where or where it
is or our combined access or who owns
this bigger object and so on and support
the type of course all the descriptors
that we will find that we can use for
develop really there is the parent
on the object itself and the depth and
the breadth as well will vary depending
on the type of thing we enable other to
do so what actually this means that
descriptor for discovery or descriptor
for citation or for example for credits
might be actually different for them
from the metadata the one required to
enable reproducibility of a certain data
sets ripple Busey beetle we require a
richer and deeper level of actually
metadata let me give you some example
now example for software digital object
software there there are several efforts
out there actually try to tackle this
area especially because all the
infrastructure that supports the
discovery and the preservation of
software like behind many of the other
digital objects and the bees and they'll
quite actually a great report from NIH
workshop which was hold in 2014 it's the
software discovery index workshop which
really documents the meal or
infrastructure around a software and and
some of the efforts which are in
progress I want to highlight one of
those effort which is called code Mita
echoed me that brings together academics
from around the world and in vendors and
and commercial entity which are
stakeholders in the area and they were
working to developing what they call it
crosswalk table they will have to
translate the different descriptors used
for code and for software and this would
certainly in announced discoverability
and reuse of software there is another
effort which is that focus on the
metadata for content to websites on in
services data services for example
and this effort is called bio schema so
biased FEMA actually brings together
groups from the age they exert on
commercial entity like Google's and many
other and it's supported the use of
schema.org which is a structured
semantic markup which is used by Google
by being by the hill by by the major
search engine and it's coordinating
distension of the schema.org into the
light science domain this is so that
data or at the ends or software or
training material standards which are
described in this served in the services
will be more discoverable by those
search engines and I want to flag that
of course a data it's one of the key
area and Luciana Machado already
presented the effort by bio County and
the data metadata index which is
underpinned by model which is also being
mapped in his press with the schema.org
vocabulary and because this lecture it's
about standards I got the flag as well
bit standard it's one of them the
content be tackled by schema.org and by
your shaving group which I will mention
later in my talk it's also participating
so this will ensure that also standards
which are described in this registry
will be more discoverable to widely use
search engines and this is all because
of the metadata the common metadata from
schema.org extended to those domain so
metadata standards are key to science
and I want to use the word that's
actually mark museum using his first
lecture opening the series well he said
that it to be a data for us you can only
be a parasite if you can actually can
access the way they can find and access
the data and the data it's available in
standard format and there is enough
metadata that you can actually
understand what the data is to reuse it
so that's really what metadata standard
are they are enablers for science to do
better so
the truth is that we already know
actually most of them today Tao the
other digital object which are shared
aren't exactly findable accessible
interoperable usable and for many
reasons because the metadata isn't rich
enough because metadata is not organized
is the a Trojan ezt because things are
not very well linked they are not very
well identified under for the novel
cited or they are not stored in the
right place and so on and so forth and
this is true also because those that
share those digital objects see this as
a very time-consuming activity having to
add rich metadata to describe your work
so that somebody else can reuse it it's
not exactly unfortunately someone
priority and circulation activity are
seeing as you know some sort of
second-class citizen type of work which
is not the case because I want to anchor
the presentation by Pascal go day about
by a tradition and importance of
professionalize decoration decoration
professionalized the use of standards in
the evacuation because this is essential
this is just an example when of any
there actually you can find of
importance of metadata so we sheriff ID
we share a data file this is this case
is in the same excel spreadsheet with
some information in it but certainly
just having here notation and with a
very clear manner in an ambiguous
expressing on a vigorous manner it's
actually key to ensure that it's
actually fair at the end this is an
example when when actually information
are unclear and they are only clear to
the person that they share it but not
return party of course this is an
example with everything it's clearer in
the suppressed and so on and so forth
let's actually now move from the
metadata standard to the content
standards so comes in standards it's a
typo metadata standards
and let me also say that this type of
classification that you see here it's
it's something that I put together and
with the with several colleagues because
there isn't an accepted way to classify
actually the type of standards but it's
it's a simple way to show that indeed
are nested so come to standard it's a
type of metadata standard which is very
much a coverage descriptor at the domain
level so and that is censured for its
interpretation at a Center for
verification reproducibility and
usability of a dataset I didn't mention
before that a metadata for society
elissa dataset it's let rich then
metadata for interpreting or reproducing
when you need an eye level of data or
what actually is being done and the
bathroom depth of those description vary
depending on the type of study one is
actually doing but generally what
dicovered it's what was done who did it
when was it done how was it done and
actually why so current and standard and
now both experimental components the
design or the condition or the parameter
of this pediment the fundamental it's a
biological entity which had been started
or any other concept which has been
studied in the analytical process all
the mathematical model and or any
simulation that has been done to be
harmonized with respect to structure
formats and allocation so then when we
share it we will actually know what part
is this pediment where is the design
where was the condition which are the
parameter so structure it's essential
not just to discovery but to interpret
to understand and then be able to reuse
it let's use an example a very very
simple example so this is just some free
text of a part of an experiment or a
very simple one so what does it mean
structuring information such information
would
means abstracting the key element the
key metadata that he come to metadata
out of this information so that when you
look at a text you will see the
structure you immediately see that
seven-week is the age and you
immediately see the demise it's actually
the strain name and this is the subject
of this experiment you immediately see
the deliverer it's actually the
anatomical part it has been used you
needed to see where the protocols are
you needed to see the type of protocol
that this information is part of and etc
now let's use another example I do work
also for for centimeter so please allow
me to use these as a simple example so
this is just a journal where data
publication are actually anchored to
structure metadata as simple as this so
if you go on the website on the center
part of the homepage you will find what
as ass brawler what the answers were
actually is it just a simple tool that
reads and visualize this parameter
metadata which has been curated by in a
curator editor which is Varsha which is
there and so she goes from free text to
structure so that what is then
implemented in the tool will allow the
user to immediately find it either paper
which is you know relevant to their type
of designer they're interested or the
type of the organ if they're very
interested or using the technology that
they are interested in a combination of
this and an account stress more the
value of actually curation and again
here have a tiny screen shot of the
Pascal presentation because it is
essential standards are enablers but
professionals like you later and those
they put at the standard in action ok so
now let's look what are the type of
contest under which are out there
there isn't any Wiley grade
classification on the content standards
and this is just the way to get some
structure to what is out there i
classifies the counter standards entry
type there are guidelines terminology
and format so the guidelines started
from right inside our what other people
also called minimal information
guidelines checklists you might know
Miami Gardens for example this was one
of the first publishing 2001 it's the
minimum information of our micro
experiments and Miami launched the trend
and there are a lot of many more
information now covering different
domain on different technology so the
guidelines are essential because at the
Community Design and define what is what
are the metadata they need to be
reported what is the essential metadata
they need to be reported that the
somebody else can actually understand
what was down there our terminology now
terminology widely covered contra
vocabulary taxonomy to salary ontology
and turn into Fords and they are
essential because we provide an
unambiguous identification and
definition of those core information
which has being reported and gene
ontology and it's an example with urban
ontology now I'm not going to go in more
detail because gentlemen ta did an
excellent job in presenting ontology the
term type of a standard it's actually
the format so and those are contained
broadly conceptual model schema exchange
format and etc and this represents the
structure which interrelate information
and will allow for example to share data
from one system to another and pass the
file it's an example of a format it is a
prototype actually of standards which is
slightly different also because it's
been developed for an somehow a in a
specific domain and it's driven specific
by healthcare industry needs
these are the common data element or CDE
which actually and they support both
patient care but also secondary use of
this data for for example this is
surveillance population of Public Health
clinical research but also inverse meant
let's look at early now a counter
standard in numbers because there are a
lot of those so I'd say that more or
less there are thousands I would say
among guideline terminology and for that
and the number comes as you can see from
the bio portal and the bio shining as a
sources combined in terms of common data
elements taken be NIH common data and
repository as a reference and there are
almost 20,000 elements here let's now
start at the community which developed
the standard the motivation is who they
are on their sample how do they create a
standard what's the life cycle of this
done there because it's very important
to understand who produced is down there
why they are being produced and etc so I
think again here there isn't a in a
great way to classify the groups but I
divide them between a de facto standard
which are the grassroots initiative like
you know the Global Alliance for German
PM held the proteomics and initiative
metabolomic and initiative the genomic
standard initiative the imaging groups
and so on and so forth so those are in a
bottom-up community which have an
interesting perhaps sharing data sharing
data between systems and the standard
which they develop are over 18 years
they are mostly volunteer effort after
they are all volunteer efforts and the
time to have very little very little
money to do the work and but also to
provide training and etc conversely you
have the standard developing
organization on the other side which a
more formal Authority the openness to
practice
question here really very not all of
them are Oakland you need to be member
or actually national natives to be from
your national representation and so far
it really depends depend on the group in
many cases the standard by those group
are actually are sold a licensed and in
the best case and out of the license at
not cost but not all of them and usually
charge supply if you want a training or
you want to programmatic access to this
downloads and that's why they're so
supportive but that's also why the
grassroot initiative struggle with funds
because everything is very everything
it's open it is a comic complex
landscape out there and in order to
understand what a group does it's it's
also important to understand that
standard be developed from different
perspective and they have a different
focus actually so there are groups which
are focused on a specific ideological or
clinical domain so they're interested in
your results but there are others they
come together because they want to model
processes or there are other which are
interested in bioimaging no matter the
sample method application so some come
from the biological perspective or and
other from the technological perspective
the motivation by which for which this
group come together also very there are
some that actually create new standard
or they want to fill a gap that the
existing between a certain standard some
actually come together to map to
harmonize effort which can be
complemented the contrasting some try to
extensions some try to repurpose
repurposed standard for other cases also
the type of people that participate in
this effort it's really very diverse and
actually should be the case because it
is essential that all the stakeholders
are represented
so it is essential to have the
technology is the one that bring the
knowledge the builders the the lead
ontology is the modelers and etc but
it's also important to have the
researcher the hand the users because
the bring the you
cases so if you meet both you meet the
consumer and the producer at the same
time and generate this group to have
representative from academia industry
governmental and funding agency as well
and you see people that are actually
involved in the sector and they cover
different roles but they all manage
somehow digital object because that's
the reason why you would want to
volunteer and participate in this effort
understanding the landscape
understanding what's out there
are we can use contests under what's
ready to use what need to be further
development etc is also being a now can
be supported it has been the focus of a
couple of and we did ok workshop on
standards and here does the reference to
one in 2013 and one in 2015 and one it
doesn't it 13 has a longer report as
well available and the other 15 also has
a report available now both workshop
have alighted that of course done the
residential we need to build we need to
understand how to help the community to
build them and and in understanding how
to help it's also important to highlight
what the challenges are and what the
pain problems are and it's both a
workshop to highlight that the paint
pots are quite a saying and it's not
just a technical problem it's also a
social problem and social engineering is
as important as technical engineering in
these cases and they also illustrate the
fact that life cycles of the standard
they seem to be quite the same
regardless the type of organization and
let me spend your captain's spend a
couple of sliding in explaining what the
life cycle of this standard development
is there are three phases the first
basis is called formulation where
actually the groups come together the
right people are assembled but that's
where it's very important to assemble
the right people to have the right
expertise that the right variety in it
Pedro Genesis as well this is when use
cases are identified the
is define what is in and what is not
what is any what is out it's also
important and and and the prioritization
is important this is just an example to
say that collecting competency question
it's one of the the first thing that
this group do and then ride them
informal questions to decide what you
know what snout and then from those
questions they start abstract what are
the the metadata that they needed and
then decide how this can be structured
and represented them etc the combination
of phase is followed by a development
phase and this is done in iteration is
usually done by a smaller group and this
is specially true in grassroots
organization when there is little money
so very few people that actually have
the time the possibility to come into
the work together for the others but
it's also important to engage
continuant in engagement with the
broader community for testing forgetting
feedback for for for having evaluation
cycles that's essential and it also an
important this phase to be able to
actually organize the different
perspective that the people working in
this path in the effort have and what
the option are the technical option and
the solution it the thing is of this
life cycle it's called maintenance now
container it's when this community start
building exemplar implementation so this
is the phase where you actually start
complement and make understand very
invisible so you have the tool the
databases and the services in me kept
being invisible and usable this is also
the phase where it's essential to have
documentation both technical
documentation but also user guides
education material some metrics by which
people can understand if they're
actually meeting or not the standards
it's also phase where the community
start think about how to sustain
themselves out of they move in the next
phase because standards it's not
something that is is done and anesthetic
it's a very dynamic
I think and science change there is a
new type of process to explore or the
processes actually enriched by a new
information or there is a new technology
out and the fourth standards it would be
extended adjusted adapted they need to
evolve a science of all different
versions and there is backward
compatibility with this version there
are commercial model and etc so it's not
a trivial thing embarking in developing
standard it's it's a kind of a lifelong
commitment I would say let me also
alight a couple of pin points because it
is important if you are a producer or if
you are a consumer of the standard to be
aware of what the difficulties is if you
are building it or you just are trying
to use it there are key issues one is
the fragmentation there are so many
activity and this is great because they
are rooted in true in real needs use
cases you know if you if you are any
pathologist why would you want to
develop a standard for plan very now of
course you don't
so you assemble the community which you
like you has the same interest but will
actually happen that because this this
community are so diverse and they have
the only you know environment to work
they might tend to duplicate unnecessary
duplicate perhaps metadata element which
are common which are common regardless
the type of biological sample news or
regarding the technology use in this
picture is accurate trying to illustrate
the problem of fragmentation now can go
on forever to explain fragmentation but
I don't want I think this actually does
give enough of a picture of the
difficulties there are other other
pinpoints besides fragmentation which is
of course you know you need to
coordinate or there or do you need to
harmonize you need to handle is tensions
how to incentivize the people to work
review all the contributors how do you
get somebody else to come in because you
need a new expertise and you argue
manage governance when you have for some
for example industry
participate or who owns the standard who
wants acceptance done but we're on the
definition of the standard do you own
the use case understand that there is no
ownership especially in grassroots
initiative but it is essential because
people want some rewards and want some
credits when contributing panda scream
from the stream it's always problem so
it's important for knowledge that
especially in HS has launched a specific
family problem for standard this is
going to be essential to help the
community
there is also an important performance
which is indicator in in evaluation
after this really hard sometimes to
understand with a standard is successful
as being successful and why has helped
in how implementation as I see that
essential is essential to me come
standard invisible so we need the tools
the outreach engagement it's it's always
critical this is the social engineering
part there is another important factor
here which is the synergy or would say
the lack of synergy between the efforts
which are around basic research and
those that come more in the healthcare
and clinical medical area there's a very
much a division there there is a divide
we need a bridge and of course the
education recommendation and training
it's really very in a time-consuming and
especially the grassroots volunteer
which are volunteer job actually
strangle to to developed last word here
keep up with updating the material and
of course a business model for
sustainability would be essential and
this is something which is you know hard
to actually identify
ok this brings me I have 14 minutes left
and brings me to some out the last part
of my other lecture well I want to more
discuss ok we have this standards we
have this wealth of standard out there
especially content standard that I'm
focusing on but I am a consumer of this
standard so where do I go to find why
needs and who can help me to find what
or or I am a producer understand I've
just but it was a beautiful format with
all my community I hope do I make sure
that my format it's actually visible to
other people which are operating in the
same area the perhaps can join forces
with us or at least I will make sure
that they're not duplicating it if I
make it visible so understanding
the standard understanding the conflicts
of standard as I see it is essential for
consumer if for a producer of the
standards and these actually are beside
the question of just the example of the
question I've just saved there are there
are many others so for example you have
curator and developers who want to use
the latest version of a certain ontology
to make sure that they are not taking it
with the rival issue or a developer
wants to create a a NASA mission tool
and wants to know what the latest form
like a database the dead database
they're targeting users so they want to
know if something has been deprecated
that they placed by something else the
researcher over course have questions
which are in a way simpler because they
just want to know which standards it's
good for their toxicological data or
which standard it's actually endorsed
which standard it's more recommended and
and in fact we also need to bear in mind
that as part of the stakeholder here
scenario there are also the funders and
the journal editors and others being
librarians or research data manager
which actually are creating guidelines
policy to the authors the over these the
research community and they also need to
be guided they also want to know they
also have the same questions which
standard will recommend in this policy
is there a list which is approved by in
this community who actually which one
they've been founded and which one are
implemented in a certain database okay
so let me give you a couple of direction
here where to go
well you can find things but let me also
tell you that there isn't a single place
where you find everything because this
is a landscape which is being mapped so
if you focus on ontology well certainly
I would say you go to the bio code so
that's where you deposit your ontology
your files and you make it visible
also because bio Porter isn't just a
repository of an ontology it provides
you with rules to do many other things
mapping annotating and etc if you are an
ontology engineering in your building in
ethology and you want to be sure that
when you build it you are following a
proper guidelines proper principle to
ensure that your ontology will be a
piece of the puzzle would be
interoperable would be orthogonal to
another ontology then I would say the
proper country is the place to go to get
the guidelines and to answer then make
sure that your your your ontology it's
also present in the other foundry so
they were part of this larger community
of people creating orthogonal ontology
now alternative it's only one type of
standards of content standards I
expressed before there are formats there
are the checklist but then there are
also the tools that implement the
standard there are the data based
implements on the standard and I think
what's important is to bring this
landscape together because in order to
tell you if a standard is mature one one
good indicator of a maturity could be
that the database has implemented
because it means that has been tested if
it is data at least you can verify and
see if that standard works for you if if
the standard has improved the quality of
the reporting of the datasets so even
indicators of maturity are not being
developed so that's the reason why I'm
also one you pointed to the bio sharing
which is also part of this helix
infrastructure the bio sharing it's a
curated and informative and educational
resource which links the standard in
this case you said the moment
only content standards to database into
policy to understand who use what so
yeah it's really to map the landscape to
monitor the development and evolution of
the standard isn't just to say oh this
standard exists is this standard the
latest version is the community still
supporting it has been implemented has
been used so the bio sharing connects to
the bio portal because it's essential
that it's the same list of terminology
and ontology but this tends to format to
model reporting Gardaland etc and link
these two databases another message that
actually I want to bring up it's that
standards are digital objects so we have
talked of books of variety about
standard being enablers they enable a
standard enable digital object to be
fair but actually standard our digital
object on their own right and they also
need to be fair so standard need to be
fundable at the very least and
accessible and of course interoperable a
reusable okay
so let's say the news portals at least
really address the findability of the
standard accessibility under standards
specifically this is one of those lines
that nobody can breathe but the reason
why I wanted to take a screenshot of a
record in the bio Shannon Porter they
describe standards in this case it's the
system biology markup language as BML
it's because also a record also the
standard needs context under its content
descriptors it is important that to be
findable the standard has its own key
descriptors so that people can use the
descriptive to find information they
want so it is important to describe the
standard to say whose group is creating
it for which taxonomic arranges the
standard applicable what area does the
standard cover and this is really tricky
so this case is of course this
computational model but it's also for
more equal entity for pathway and etc
important to turn to the standard way to
make it discoverable it's important to
say if there is support who the groupies
who is maintaining the record who is
affidavit in the record who is funded
the standards are the fabrication
associated and they related standard and
so on and so forth and this is what we
meant mapping the landscape described in
the standards so that's found about but
doesn't just mean that in order for a
consumer to actually pick the right one
and the writing quotation I say you need
to have indicators now those indicators
as of now do not exists but this is what
actually is being developed and and
hopefully pretty soon there will be a
set of indicators that to help you
choose and those indicator will be rich
and richer as the community agrees on
what is the right indicator to use so at
the moment in the bio Shelley for
example use only few indicator to start
with at least marks what's really
different limitation what's in
development what's until a certain and
what's being duplicated and though this
tag are actually back to it with the
community which is behind the standards
and uncertain status might mean that
correct the group is no longer active so
the standards there is still good
perhaps could be even used by databases
but yeah the community behind it is no
longer active in developments is just
started ready to use and implement
implementation means it's added ready
and not yet been implemented or even
been implemented
let me show an example using them
standards by the links group which is
part of the NH with it ok so these are
just two records they show the link
standard for a report in SN line its
reporting guided on the left-hand side
it's a version which has been duplicated
so it's a version 1 duplicated which has
been superseded by another version 2 and
this is important because you might have
people who have use the version 1 and
they need to understand that they still
need to find the version of the standard
but they will need to be directed
it's to use the latest version and and
when is possible and when is known the
file-sharing works with the community in
this case the links community to
understand the reason for this in this
case this duplication and justify the
reasons so that this reason becomes
public and somebody who comes to the
registry and look for the or come and
discover the link stander knows the whys
being duplicated so searching the
standard can be tricky and is tricky at
the moment because you know it's
important to classify them and
categorize them and this portal it's
work in progress of course but it's also
also an ally the fact that there are
ways to get packaged information so
there are way to package a sectoral
standard that perhaps it's it's
important for your domain you know it's
around it's around how to information or
it's for for clinical data or it's for
imaging it's possible to actually
package and group records and we are
working with the community to try to
prep a courage the the standards so that
we can direct you to a group of standard
for a certain domain and so I make you
after the search and the discovery
easier but I want to go one level deeper
and not at all you have a few but four
minutes in front of me I should actually
make it this is the last topic I will
cover it's about it's going deeper now
so why I'm sure you hear it's that the
tree type of standard garden terminology
format actually are related to each
other there are relations they need to
be built for sample naturally to know
what guidelines it's implemented by
database so actually if there is a
terminology which the guideline
recommends or if there is a format that
the guidelines recommend we don't what
we built is a relation and we need them
discoverable so that sound that are used
it's a complex web of relation and let
me give you an example a very simple one
so the left-hand side you see two
databases
taken the most you know well-known
databases and CBI GL and EB IRS press
for gene expression data transcriptomics
data now both databases implement the
checklist a reporting garden called
Miami right but actually the two
databases require different type of
formats for data submission jr.
implements the beam email format and not
just that one on one out too many
I just want to simplify the example at
this press requires a data submission in
each time now this relation in to be
billed and indeed what I'm showing to
you that's those databases he was more
than just that standard they use more
standards and nevertheless they both use
the same reporting guidelines
implemented in different format
expressed with different terminology so
if somebody wants to if a developer
comes and say oh I want to build a data
submission to geo I told the submitted
the geo which is the stand of Jews they
would be able to actually trace back and
understand looking at the registry
looking at these relations so a couple
of slides here which seems very hard to
read but actually are hard to read
really show you how this network
relation it's it's it's it's really it's
really quite complicated and although
it's very useful so this is just an
illustration of the relation between
standard databases in policy which are
recommended by by different journals but
the bridge support illustrating this
this relation is essential because as
you can see from this very now dense a
graph network graph here
it's what I'm showing you here it's that
although there is a relation between
certain standard databases the policy
recommend there are many more standards
or in databases there for example a
journal could recommend that a user
could pick that's relevant to two he or
she but
actually they're not necessary
immediately seeing because there is so
much and the user need to be guided you
need to be guided if you're looking for
the right standard so what we are
creating it's a sort of network that
will inform a guide what's really
important let me only point to very
briefly on the right hand side for
example you can actually see orange dots
that represent databases which are
recommended by the Plus data sharing or
the same okay but as you can see those
data this year it is a model databases
all of them use a standard all of them
use an ontology which is go which is in
gray and is just behind
so body showing to the post editor that
actually those databases the very
command also use a standard will be
essential because the Plus policy can
evolve and if Rebecca man go as a
standards as well for the annotation and
crediting and recommendation of the
standard as well and so and so broader
visibility it is essential to help the
community to actually keep building it
make it even reusable and etc and I've
just realised from my watch that I've
reached the 50 minutes and I want to
close with this summary slide which
actually isn't besides of reading
materials lives which counts again to
report from the tweenage workshop which
are I think very informative in terms of
of out standards metadata in in
community and many people have
contributed to those workshop and the
report I also want to point you to them
fair paper by Woking turn at all and
also a report that myself and a
colleague have put together as a part of
the Wellcome Trust literature review in
pink face which unfortunately is still
being made available but this is the
link and I've been told that in a week
or so will be available and I want to
close with a message that says that
actually as the data science grow
digital output are being recognized as
first-class citizen I think we
to go a further step one step further
and also recognized that standards and
interoperability standard are digital
object in their own right and they have
to come with a known associate of
research development in educational
activity thank you
Susannah that was really outstanding
thank you so much for this fantastic
lecture on metadata standards and so
comprehensive really a tour de forest
lecture thank you so we do have a few
questions already lined up I'd like to
encourage those of you listening to if
you have some questions you can use the
question feature on the GoToWebinar
panel there on the probably right side
of your screen and to encourage you to
submit some questions and we'll try to
get to them all if we have time the
first question that is got my attention
here is what suggestions do you have
Suzanna for how to bridge the experts
the decision makers and the implementers
in this process of standards
developments of use and practice well
the best advice it's really what the
community are doing they are actually
bringing those stakeholder at the table
from the beginning at the formulation
phase so it is essential and as I stated
during the lifecycle that the
formulation phase includes all
stakeholders not the one that they will
build with the standards but also the
one that they will use it and implement
it it is essential to bring them at the
table from the very beginning it does
ensure adoption but he will certainly
give the best shot yeah I would say that
that is a very important element of this
rather wise you run this danger of a
sort of not invented here sort of
syndrome among some people who may feel
that they got alienated somehow one
other question is can you talk about
taking that taking ontology and
standards and making them computable
using the Semantic Web
now d'epinay well semantic web
technology it's
it's a it's widely used by many of this
standard committee I mean when I say
format as I say this is really broad
there are standard which are expressing
our yes for example so absolutely so is
the when when one has data dictionaries
for metadata standards are these these
sort of go hand in hand is there any
sort of implication about reproducible
science that one can draw from the role
of having data dictionaries linking them
with standards and then using those to
help promote reproducible science does
that make sense
what was the don't think I picture I
think we all have information for every
narrative to keep track of all the terms
and for data dictionary I think it's
just really that you know the list of
it's almost in itself and it's almost a
conflated concept in the sense that
you've got a data a data element and it
has say a range or a data type and these
are allowed values if it's a missing
value at my whole this sort of a value
and so it's almost on one hand it's sort
of all synonymous with an ontology or
some sort of metadata standard but
perhaps there's a subtle distinction
there or we really talked about the same
thing well I think that it's a subtle
distinction and to be honest the
classification that are showing about
you know guideline terminology in format
it's really you know it's it's really
just a way to try to classify things
because you know I I have call it the
data to that ontology are have a
structure and the format of course they
are they are spread in a format there
especially now they're expressing or in
noble format so I think it's very very
hard to try to you know a box it these
things because there are slightly
different way to structure the
information and and it's hard to say
which is the right way the problem is
because there is such a variety of way
to structure in this press the standards
there
there is a lot of fragmentation as well
but he's also some tactics
yeah yeah someone once said the best
thing about standards is that there's a
lot of them there is a little bit of it
is kind of a I don't know there is a
variety of them and people will often
vote with their feet on which one they
seem to like and it does the best job
and it kind of gets also to the point of
versioning of standards and I'm sure you
you probably touched on this at least in
brief or in part and I'm wondering how
that factors into the evolution of
standards and how important that is and
if you wanted to comment it's actually
essential essential well I would say
that actually probably versioning it's a
in terms of practice its its use
especially in gerontology in the
ontology world but it's also true in
terms of formatting as well so so again
here the practice is not a widespread
and still heterogeneous depending on the
community and depending on their
approach right if we have probably let's
see are there any other questions here
so one question is one last one is are
there any emergence of metadata
standards which have been developed
specifically for computational sciences
it's a you might be aware of
I'll definitely refer you especially to
the combined group combined brings
together computational modeling system
biology
it's called combined a spell assad's
exactly combined and brings brings the
right eye for standard perhaps this
person is interested otherwise please
come to me and I'll try to actually
point to the right one that sounds
wonderful
well everyone we're at the top of the
hour now and I'd like to thank Susanna
once again for a really fantastic
enriched a survey of metadata standard
and all that that entails I want to
thank you all for joining us this
morning and to once again tune in next
week as they say for our next in our
series of data science seminars enjoy
your weekend thank you again thank you
for having me thank you thank you
Susanna